hey everyone I think we're
gonna get started here the title of my
talk is web first data visualization in
Python I'm gonna be covering a project
called lightning that I helped develop
my name is Matthew Conlon a little bit
about me I work at 5:38 I'm a
computational journalist there which
means I do a lot of data visualization
for their stories I also work with
Jeremy Freeman in the Freeman lab at HMI
Genelia which is where this project
comes comes from if anyone was around
yesterday to see the binder talk this is
the same same lab so first question I
want to address with lightning is like
do we really need yet another way to
plot data on the screen and probably not
this this isn't trying to be like an
end-all be-all charting library it's not
trying to replace ggplot or anything
like that really the goal of lightning
is to connect your data where you're
doing the analysis and where you already
have the data and two visualizations
that people have already made so
especially on the web using javascript
in d3 we want to be the bridge between
those two things so yeah you want to
keep your analysis code where where
you're comfortable with it in Python or
in R if you're one of those people and
then use kind of the best tools for the
job when you're actually doing the data
visualization side of things and so from
my perspective that is JavaScript and d3
and we want to use all the modern
libraries that are available this was
kind of built out of a frustration of my
own that you could go to blocks or all
these really cool examples of
interactive visualizations online you
could see the code you could see how
they run but there's no way to like put
your own data into these like they're
just stuck on the web as they're
interactive but they're also static so
lightning provides a way to pipe your
data into these things really easily and
the way that it does that is by exposing
an API so this is kind of like
the tagline for the project provides an
API based access to reproducible web
visualizations and the way that really
works is that there's a REST API you
send JSON to it
you say I have this data I'm going to
provide you with it in the post request
and I want it to be displayed with this
type of chart so you can say like I want
a line graph or I want a scatter plot or
whatever and it will generate a webpage
a URL an image whatever you whatever way
you exact like exactly want it to be
displayed that's how it will return so
here's an example like this is all
you're sending in the post requests and
then you get back like this page with
your visualization on it this one in
particular is rendered with 3GS so it's
a 3d scatter plot but it's kind of
whatever type of visualization you want
it to be so we we provide a few defaults
but you can plug in any JavaScript
visualization to the system and I'll
show you exactly how to do that later on
so client-server model is kind of the
basis for this whole thing we have this
nice abstraction between our analysis
code and the code that's doing the
rendering of this stuff and it gives
like a few benefits right off the bat
that you wouldn't necessarily expect
like one we automatically get like
updating and streaming on our
visualizations since they're persistent
and they have this service backing them
their rep reducible so if you have data
and you create it you can just do the
same exact thing with new data and you
you'll be able to see different changes
over time like there's no you're not
messing with HTML files or just like
putting your data into some JSON blog or
something like that it's all in your
workflow and like very solid
that's shareable you get a link you can
send it to your friends and show it off
and you can also get state so like if
the user is interacting with the
visualization you can you can query that
and say like what is the current state
of this visual
what has the user done to interact with
it and you can sort of do further
analysis based on that so this is just a
quick what what the website looks like
if you go here these are kind of all of
the visualizations that we have by
default I think there's like maybe 15 or
so I know if you click into any of them
any one of them you get this like live
editor that shows you okay this is what
our line visualization looks like you
can play around with it it's all
interactive and then you can actually
change the data and stuff down here to
see exactly how it will respond to you
so if you ever want to just get like a
quick overview of what this can do just
go to the website light name is Dorgan
you can play around with this editor so
here's another example a little weirder
one this is a 3d volume rendering of a
color cube and you can see it's this
one's rendered with 3GS again and if you
like scroll down here there's always a
example code that shows exactly how this
thing was created so here's the Python
on the site that was used to create this
this visualization so to set this up
there's a few ways to go about it
because it is a client-server model you
need the server this is written a node
you can install it with NPM we give you
an executable it's like a one-line
install you can install it via a binary
that we distribute for OSX or we
actually have a public server running so
this link public lightning does org if
you don't want to go through the trouble
of like setting up your own local server
you can just start using that and it
will work out of the box for you for
python we actually provide the ability
to do all this without a server at all
but you use you lose some of the
benefits and I'll talk a little bit more
about like the pros and cons of doing
that it's good for like high performance
type situations and situations where you
don't want to be bothered to install the
server pretty quick testing or something
like that
but I recommend usually going with the
server room if you download the app this
is the screen you get it's a typical OS
X you just right drag it into
applications and launch it and you'll
have a server running on your computer
once it's running this is what it looks
like you get a welcome screen with a
sidebar things are kind of bucketed into
sessions so that you can keep track of
visualizations that you've made but the
cool thing is you can see this page all
the visualizations that are in here so
each one of these is something that you
can send data to and have it display
with your data and then you can click
through and see exactly what that looks
like and you can even like since these
are all JavaScript modules you can use
this page to import new ones or custom
ones that you make and at the end I'll
go through an example of doing that this
is a Python setup it's pretty easy
hopefully everyone is familiar with this
if you don't like pip you can clone it
from it's not github searching lightning
is Python will give you that link so
here's the first kind of simplest Python
example okay so first two lines are just
importing the libraries the second one
where we instantiate the client LG N
equals lightning we pass in the host so
I don't have a server running locally
for this example but I pass in this
public URL so that tells it use that as
my backing server then I create some
random data I'm using numb PI's random
function and I plot a line plot so that
line V equals LG n dot line is what's
actually plotting it we get a reference
to the plot and then we can call it open
and we'll open it in your browser like
this and since we're using the public
server like you have a link that you can
send to people now these are all on the
public server they're all anonymized and
in the same way that github gist's work
like secret gists so no one can find
your visualizer
but if you share the link then people
will be able to access them and so in in
this line here next to six LG n dot Lian
the LG n object has a function for every
single different plot type basically so
there's a dot line scatter dot histogram
all this stuff and this is kind of the
lists of everything that's in there by
default you can go through I'm not going
to go through everything right now this
is all in the documentation but it's
just exposed as a function on the
top-level object that you can call you
just pass in your data and whatever
options you want to provide so another
cool thing that you can do is same as
the last example but now I'm providing a
description field so this is a pure
markdown description that I can add in
when I'm plotting and since I already
showed you that you get like a web URL
for this it will render this markdown
next to your visualization so if you
want to annotate anything or provide
detailed descriptions of the analysis
that you did to get there or anything
like that you can use this tool to
create like a like nice standalone web
page that can represent all the work
that you put into this it also works in
notebooks and Jupiter and ipython to do
this you just have to pass in an i
python flag set it to true and then by
default everything will just start
showing up in line here and of course
it's all interactive and the three end
stuff so these are just kind of our
sample scatter plots and the different
options that you can pass in but
everything works just out of the box in
an IDE Python like this
here's the link if you want to see these
example at notebooks there's a whole
collection of them they go through
pretty much every single different plot
type that we have and go into detail on
all the different options and things
that you can pass in I'd recommend
checking this out it's like a good first
starting point if you're not familiar
with the library yet yeah by the way if
anyone has any questions at any point
just feel free to stop me yeah so like
for example in yeah yeah so I think one
of the things that is different there is
that there's also plot types that are
images too so there's like maybe four
there that aren't showed up shown up
but in general it's it's the one-to-one
mapping of everything that's in there
will be on the top level it may be it's
possible that something just got cut off
of the screenshot too but yeah
so certain parts of it are part of the
API like different colors and sizes and
axes labels and stuff like that are
passed in as configuration options and
then if you want to do like much more
in-depth customization than that you can
drop in to the JavaScript and do it that
way and I'm gonna go through an example
of doing exactly that at the end cool
everyone else on board at annotations
we've got our notebooks it's in okay so
in addition to just being able to create
these things I mentioned that we can
actually get information back about like
what the user is doing here so actually
every single visualization that you
create it stores just an arbitrary
dictionary of key value pairs that are
defined per visualization so scatter
plot could have like selected points for
example and then you're able to query
that at any given point and see what the
user has done and sort of take further
action based on that so this is a more
concrete example this is using one of
the image rendering functions so I'm
taking the example images from
scikit-learn and using it to just
display images with this type called
lightening image poly and what image
poly allows you to do is draw polygons
overtop of the image so if you want to
annotate or select certain regions of
the image you can go in and and select
it here the selections are stored in
this dictionary so if at any given point
if the user has made selections you can
get that information back and then sort
of run subsequent analysis or do
whatever you want with that information
so I mean in this example I'm just like
creating a new plot with those
predefined but you can imagine doing I
don't know any sorts of things with this
like running more in-depth regressions
and just like one part of your data or
whatever
so that's what this is good for it's
also possible to define callbacks this
is only possible in the Jupiter notebook
environment but in a similar way you can
listen for events and say like on this
event run this Python function and I
don't have an example of this but it's
basically the same same ideas what's
going on here except you have to query
so you can also update the data in the
plots and append data to it so
everything that every plot that you
create has an update and an append
method and update just completely
replaces the data that's inside of there
append adds it to the end of the array
in a way that makes sense and some of
them are particularly well suited for
these types of operations so we have
some streaming types of visualizations
so like we have a normal line plot but
we also have a streaming line plot it
was a normal scatter plot we also have a
streaming scatter plot which all of the
differences is that it makes the append
method much nicer so if you're using
append on this streaming line plot this
is what it'll look like so you can use
this to build kind of cool dashboards
and things like that and see how it's
changing over time this is the complete
code to generate that it's very similar
to the first example I showed except
we're just appending or using lines the
line streaming function then we're
appending at the end similarly with the
scatter plot we can have streaming
scatter plot to where points fade out
over time and come in over time and you
can define different behaviors based on
that and it's the same idea here you
just do a streaming scatter plot and
you're appending data to it all the time
so you can run this in Python without a
server there are a few advantages one is
faster you don't have to do a round-trip
to the server and back
you're just piping straight out of
Python and the way that we do this is
basically by bundling up all of the
JavaScript that the server would
normally provide minifying it and
packaging it with the Python client the
sort of disadvantages of this is are
they like that javascript is then stuck
there like you can't add new custom
visualization types to it you only get
the default ones and you don't get this
cool like persistence and you don't get
the ability to query for the states so
it's it's a fully-featured d3
interactive plot but it doesn't have all
this stuff behind it really so just
going to talk now quickly on what
exactly goes into making a custom
visualization so everything in here is a
module if anyone's familiar with
JavaScript and NPM everything is a
module on NPM in the same way that it
would be a package on pie-pie for
example so every single visualization
that we have flavors in a separate
github repo they're all super easy to
find and that the code is nice nicely
separated so if you want to make any
changes you can go to github and check
out the code and see exactly how
everything works there's no magic to it
there are a few advantages of doing it
this way one is that this allows the
server to build the packages on demand
which means that we can require any
JavaScript library that's on NPM so if
you want to have a new visualization
that uses some crazy new library that
came out like last week you can do that
without updating the server at all like
it just plugs in you can start using
them and to start making your own or
customizing these things we provide a
Yemen generator which will just skeleton
out like a little project for what a
custom visualization looks like it's
really just one javascript file that
looks like this so it's you're extending
the base lightening visualization and
you basically have to fill in a few
questions here it's like an init
function and a rendered function and
then a function to transform data if you
need it to be transformed in any way so
for example this is just a JavaScript
charting library called chart.js
if you wanted to plug this in to
lightning and start like creating plots
from your Python code what you would do
is you would have this structure and
then you'd go in let's say you
essentially you would fill in the init
function which is it needs a canvas on
the screen so I draw a canvas and you
fill in the render function it needs to
be initialized with this chart library
JavaScript and then you can just go to
this screen on your server and type in
the module name I just called it I think
lightning custom example for this one
just because it was a test but what this
is going to do when I hit submit is it
goes on to NPM it pulls down the package
it compiles it and brings it into your
Lightning server environment and then
you're going to be able to start using
it in interacting with it in the same
way that you can interact with it with
all the default visualizations so like
that live editor that you saw before and
like the Python API is will exist so it
takes a few like 10 or 20 seconds to
actually come in but now you have this
visualization that lightning is
rendering you can actually go in and
it's all alive you can change the data
and you can call this from Python it's
like just completely in the ecosystem
now and it's really really easy to like
get it in there which is the idea of
this whole thing let's see
oh yeah that is what I have for you
I went over pretty quickly all of the
kind of high-level functionality so if
anyone has particular questions I'd be
happy to answer them
so there's hemp two answers is like one
if it's already exposed through like the
options parameters you can just pass it
and through Python it if it's something
that that does that doesn't work the
process would be like you clone the
version of it that's on github locally
you make your changes there and then you
in that same like panel that I showed to
bring it in you would just bring in your
local version and it like depending on
how long the changes take I mean you can
do it in like five minutes or something
cool no notes yeah
yeah I mean that would be that would be
great I would love if people did that um
a few ways that we do that now or try to
help people do that is just through one
the project like this skeleton generator
it includes a few key words so like if
you publish any custom visualization
that you made using that generator it's
tagged under like a lightning vis
keyword so those are all searchable and
indexed on NPM so you can see all the
all the ones that people have made that
way yeah the the other thing is just
getting more buy-in from like JavaScript
people I think it's been the project has
been pretty popular on the Python side
of things but not a ton of JavaScript
love right now so but yeah if if people
want to make them and we're happy to
share and like make them available for
anyone who who contributes one cool is
thank you for listening